Republicans in the house and who are
running for the House of Representatives
are increasingly facing pressure to
impeach Joe Biden if they were to take
control of the house in November the
only problem is impeach him for what
they don't agree of course Joe Biden has
not done anything impeachable but you've
got some Republicans saying impeach
Biden for what he did in Afghanistan of
course Donald Trump had the exact same
plan for Afghanistan there are others
saying impeached Joe Biden for what he's
done on immigration and of course not
that much has changed on immigration
from the time Trump was President so
that one doesn't really make sense
others say impeach Joe Biden because of
what he did in Ukraine and of course
when you ask them well what what did he
do that's worthy of impeachment they
don't really know where they're confused
so this will be very interesting if
Republicans do take the house which they
are expected to
will they impeach Biden I believe the
answer is yes but more importantly for
what it doesn't even seem they can agree
on it